on january 26th of 2020
i lost my wife in the same helicopter
crash that killed kobe bryant
matt mouser the singer who lost his wife
christina mauser in the helicopter crash
that killed kobe bryant gianna bryant
and six
others last year just wowed the judges
on america's got talent
with his impressive performance i was in
tears myself
knowing that i was going to meet with a
man who was going through tremendous
grief for a whole family
and matt tells e.t he's doing it all to
set an example for his kids
you have to take challenges you have to
take risks and
you have to continue so that's that's
what we're doing on tuesday's episode of
the nbc competition show
the 51 year old took the stage and
introduced himself
before revealing to the judges the
heartbreaking details of his life over
the past
year and a half before january 26th
me and christina lived this dreamy kind
of life
in a pre-taped package matt talked about
his relationship with christina
something the show's host terry crews
told et
was hard to do while we were talking
during our interview
um he was like man i don't know if i can
do this
and this is before he actually went on
stage
and i said and i told him i said you
know i understand if you didn't
i totally do and uh but i and i
let him know i said but we are here not
to use you we are here to help you
whatever you want to do however
you want to help your family by doing
this we
are here for you and he decided to do it
it was so
courageous christina and matt met in
2004 when she saw him performing with
his band at a dive bar
and the pair hit it off she was just
this
very humble powerful beautiful human
being
my mom said if you don't marry that girl
you're you're stupid
we were married for 15 years we had
three beautiful children
it was filled with love he
also recalled the morning of the tragic
accident
when she left that day she kissed me and
she said
i love you that was the last thing my
wife ever said to me
in the days after the crash matt said
his focus went to his children
and he knows his wife would want him to
carry on
and for their kids to have happy lives i
don't know what's possible
but i'm going to try matt and
christina's three children were at the
audition to support their dad
and cheer him on how did it feel for you
to have
your babies in the wings they're
watching you
take a courageous step forward in your
healing process
i was glad they were there i needed them
there i got some great advice
let them see you grieve and let them see
you live
and those that's what you have to do so
it's really important that they were
there
his song choice phil collins 1984 single
against
all odds
cause i'll still be standing here
and you coming back to me is against all
odds and that's what i've got to face
and when e.t chatted with matt on
wednesday he opened up about the
significance of that specific
song there's one lyric in there that
was really kind of uh appropriate for me
and it was um
there's so much i i need to say to you
so many reasons why you know you're the
only one who really knew me at all and
that's just so true
and uh you know when you lose that
sounding board when you lose the person
who
you've confided in you lose you know the
most important person in your life
like i said you you know you just have
to
kind of against all odds find a way back
not only did he get a standing ovation
for his performance
it's a little uh emotional a little
overwhelming
the judges loved it we felt your emotion
if you're able to move strangers and
move and we can feel it in our hearts
there aren't words to describe it it was
beautiful it was sad and as a man as a
strong man
standing there it i don't know it was
very special
it was very emotional very touching
thank you thank you for being here
and there wasn't a dry eye in the house
after simon cowell
asked matt what he hoped to get out of
being on agt
i would like to make sure that my
children see
that in spite of the grief that we've
been through this year and that that
grief is not going to define who we are
as a family and and that my children see
that you have to find joy in life and
you have to continue
if this can any way help my children who
chase their dreams then i'll take it
[Applause]
the judges gave matt the four yes votes
needed to move on to the next round of
the competition
and matt reiterated that he did it all
for his little ones during his chat with
e.t
how did this audition come to you or how
did you
maybe get the idea or decide to go
through this process of auditioning for
agt
the main reason i did it is because i
want to make sure that
my kids saw me do something you know
instead of just being sad
you know we've been mourning for about a
year now and we've been in a
obviously a lockdown and so it was one
of those opportunities that we had and
when life presents an opportunity to
[Music]
take
you